welcome everyone to
uh brilliant minds bold questions a
five-part virtual event series exploring
questions being addressed by some of the
world's top researchers
each talk pair speakers and moderators
from across disciplines sectors in
the world to explore the question
shaping our future
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
canadian-based global organization that
convenes extraordinary minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and humanity
my name is rachel parker and i'm senior
director of research at cfar
and it's my pleasure to introduce to you
dan resnick and woody powell today
dan is an expert on the globalization of
rapid innovation-based industries and
has led pioneering research on the
distributional impact of innovation
policies
woody's interests focus on the processes
through which
ideas and practices are transferred
across organizations
and the role of networks in facilitating
or hindering innovation
today we will explore growth and equity
can we have both
woody i'd like to turn it over to you
now to ask the first question
sure thank you rachel dan thank you for
uh your new book on innovation and real
places we'll talk a little bit about
what you think of as unreal places i
have a feeling
my territory out here in california is
one such
place in your mind but you look at
innovation that's not focused on silicon
valley or seattle or shenzhen
but rather on opportunities in
communities that don't
normally get considered when one thinks
about them as
centers of prosperity because i want to
start by asking you is an innovation
fundamentally
about breaking rules and challenging
existing ways of doing things
and does it always have to have an
outsider quality to it
thank you uh woody and yes
just by your question it is very clear
that you come from silicon valley which
is
slightly unreal uh no so i would say
that unfortunately in the last few years
our debate especially public debate
about innovation has been completely
divorced
from reality and we forgot what
innovation is
there is that thing which is called
invention coming up with new ideas for
products or services
innovation is actually putting that
ideas
into reality in the marketplace
and that includes all stages from coming
up with
idea to after service
production assembly design this is the
real innovation and if you want to uh
see real innovation in action creating
widespread prosperity
uh forget silicon valley come with me to
taiwan
come with me to finland come with me to
germany
indeed you know unless you really like
tesla and by the way
even if you like tesla open it up and
you'll find out that most of it is
bosch a german company i know alan
doesn't like that but that's the truth
um
and that's where you really have
innovation and that
through that movement through those
stages
through that constant and continuous
improvement changing tweaking
is where you got real uh advantage
to welfare and real economic growth and
prosperity
just think for a moment about the
millions of engineering
hours that have been put into the
innovation of how to
improve the cpu the memory
the fiber optics the
amount of data you can move in the fiber
optics so you and i can now
talk on zoom
you said a number of things there i want
to explore you
expanded the idea of innovation to think
about invention in every stage of
production
you also added this idea of continuous
improvement those are
two things that are sort of different
than you know the one big
uh disruptive idea you also
mentioned countries like taiwan finland
israel is another example that
are very diverse on some dimensions but
seem to be places
quite different from say the traditional
centers
and the tech capitals where the gains of
innovation are shared more widely
so what's the relationship between this
continuous
improvement at every stage of production
and being in a society where more people
benefit
from these advancements sure so let me
uh
let me go back to the places that you
mentioned
um i think that one thing that we unders
have to understand
uh and and that's why in the book there
is another title
which is about globalization
once you have globalization and the way
we have a globalization meaning
that you take a product or service you
basically now
uh defragmented
to several stages in in
each country or place in the world now
does
those things so let's think about the
semiconductor industry for a moment
the us has a beautiful one uh israel has
a great one
taiwan has a great one korea has a great
one
and yet and in those places some of the
same companies working
all those places but what they do in
those places
are completely different so in silicon
valley and in israel
they try to put new ideas on silicon
but they as we now know thanks to intel
and what happened in the united states
without the taiwanese company called
tsmc we no longer know how to put those
items on silicon
and that's where taiwan excels in korea
when you buy any mobile phone including
an apple
the second highest amount of profit now
occurs to samsung
which control critical things that go to
every smartphone on earth um
that also tells you where you have
a power over the network and
let me just in this small examples
taiwan
and korea might have actually more power
on the whole network on the mobile
phones
than silicon valley right now the second
is
those different kinds of innovation
necessary different skills
different finance provide to the
community
completely different kinds of employment
so you mentioned
israel which is a small country and
everybody thinks is a great economic
miracle
versus taiwan let's say or finland
unfortunately
as somebody has done a lot of research
on on all
but also grew up in israel what happened
in israel because israel imitates
silicon valley it might be
the only case of a place that actually
managed to imitate silicon
valley fully israel is now one of the
most un just like silicon valley
one of most unequal places on earth as a
matter of fact in the same years we have
this
massive economic miracle the israeli
society
went that way uh and right now
one out of every five household in
israel
is under the poverty line and basically
on a treadmill to nowhere
while only the graduates of the best
universities
best technological units where financier
and celebrity chefs
are enjoying high-end silicon valley
wages and a lottery ticket called
you know stock options for an ipo
so i think one of the real questions
that real places should have is
why do you want to have innovation why
spend taxpayers money on innovation
if you're a small city and there if the
reason is
i want to create prosperity for my
citizen my residence
imitating silicon valley even if you can
be successful
might be the wrong guns um
we saw the uh a good example of what we
were describing with
semiconductors with u.s automakers where
they're having a slow or stop production
for trucks uh because of the lack of
access to
um uh to chips from taiwan at the moment
so
these global production networks are
hugely important
okay so israel is a case of replication
without the gains
let's think more about how innovation
could be pursued and the gains can be
more widely shared
so one of the messages i took from your
book was
don't try to emulate these you know
canonical places
but then i'm sure people want to know
what dreams should cleveland ohio have
brampton ontario or birmingham uk what
what can be the ways they um
pursue innovation policies in the
context
of old industries let us say
so first let's talk about an old
industry and let me give you an example
of one of the oldest industries in the
world
uh shoes you know the things you put on
on your foot and let's talk about
high-end luxury woman shoes
and once you look at that industry which
by the way create a lot of prosperity
you found out that one of the places
which has the
highest and the most sustained
prosperity for people who are not just
designer from you know top end schools
is rivera de brenta in italy just about
venice and the reason is that they focus
on what i call the second stage of
innovation so if you're a
wonderful designer from milan or perry
or new york
and you design a really cool shoe and
you say
okay now this shoe has to be made i have
to be able to sell it for an x amount of
price and a real human being has to wear
that shoes and if a real human being is
paying 2 000 euros
they might actually want to walk on it
from time to time so it cannot just
explode the place that will make that
happen for you
is brenta and it's set of suppliers
very high-end suppliers very high-end
uh if you want to think about it
designing of how you make
an idea into a product running out
into production very high in the
production selling it to you
and by the way woody if you're not
creative enough this year and you had
only a hundred
new shoes and you need 200 you can also
get the brent of people to come up with
another 100
and that's very wide prosperity for
people from the
those who can actually design shoes the
creatives
to the people who know how to put you
know the soul to the end of a shoe and
sell it sounds like a story of the
rediscovery of craft
and in one way
you know that rediscovery is a form of
invention taking something that's been
around for a long time
applying it to new settings paying
attention to skill
so that more and more people are
involved in learning that skill
is there a difference in our educational
systems
between places that focus
more on you know high-end computer
science and finance versus those that
[Music]
are more skilled
to a degree yes um and definitely in the
case of brent
but if i'll go to taiwan since we
mentioned it again
taiwan is also known for i don't know if
you
ride bikes but if you ride bikes
especially
especially if you move to mountain bikes
a few years ago
by definition you had the taiwanese
product mostly
almost surely from giant uh
and what you see in taiwan is again they
took a very
old product basically it's a diamond
frame designed 200 300 years ago
and infuse it with new technologies in
that case new materials
so you can make the bike
go on off-road light enough for people
who are not
looking like you know superman to
actually carry it
into the mountain and start mountain
biking um
what is interesting here and the reason
i wanted to say
you need extremely high-end material
science in order to do that
but you also need the people who
produces um
that means that while you have a very
very
high-end universities and and almost
fundamental research
and researchers in taiwan what they do
in taiwan
how they use those skills and the
incentives that they get
in order to use those skills finance and
other are different
so again depending on your stage and
depending how you attack it
and depending if you're cleveland and
you have
an amazing university an amazing health
system
or if you're hamilton ontario and you
have the same or you're in a place
which close closer to brenta if you want
to think about
and you still have those craft skills as
you call them
design a strategy around that design a
strategy around a different stage of
production
do not assume that if you don't become
new york silicon valley or tel aviv
you cannot innovate and gain prosperity
and unfortunately
as as we have talked before that
conversation
no longer exists with policymakers they
all think that if they're not silicon
valley of the north
you know i'm in canada so at least 15
cities claim that title
we're not innovative and i think it's a
miss service
to her own residents to think that way
it's a really important insight i i take
from it a couple of things
[Music]
one through all the stories and and your
wonderful book
there is this focus on continuous
updating whether it's bicycles or
shoes you know so there's a drive to
constantly make these things better um
and better doesn't involve um
disruption often involves making things
better
so the consumers will you know like them
more
they'll be lighter they'll be more
durable there are a lot of positives
for many people in that you use the word
incentives
okay we typically think of incentives as
tax breaks government funding
i don't think those are the kinds of
incentives you mean though
i'll say let's let's be very clear
some of them are okay there's a lot of
role for government
and much of a role for government
especially with innovation
which is risk is indeed
uh with creating those incentives that
you just talked about
but the other set of incentives and
again it's a public
private policy is
a vision of iu you want your society
a vision of of status and and
what those people want to have
but also a set of regulations
that allow or disallow different kind of
business models
even if a lower short-term profit
which i think is really important right
now
speaking about semiconductors
manufacturing
intel it may be the one last american
company that can
announce that it is investing 20 billion
dollars
in having fabrication or manufacturing
sites for semiconductors
without the ceo being fired
within five minutes by wall street
analyst and their friends
um and those are kinds of incentives
which
we don't talk about in a polite company
but i think that especially in north
america we should
um i hear you doing two things with that
statement
one telling us an important lesson which
is that we should
care as much about the uh the person who
builds the bike
the person who crafts the shoes the
person who bravely makes a decision to
invest
in a new fab plant
as we should you know the 26 year old
wunderkind who comes up with
you know the new way to take a vacation
or
to have food delivery so that's a
rethinking of
who the stars of innovation are there's
also lots of discussion though about
innovation as
something that leads to gains for only a
few
and i think that's well we'll turn to
the audience now and rachel you're in
charge of that
um to help us think more broadly about
what are ways to make
innovation more inclusive before we turn
to the audience and i have a question
that i want to
to ask for um uh do
do you want to respond to dan or um
sure so let me just be very clear of it
that's exactly the reason why
we and when i say we i mean you i
rachel and another 12 people uh
have created a new c4 program which is
called innovation
equity in the future of prosperity and
it's exactly that fear
uh that we have um or that many have
that innovation at least in the last 20
years
means that the few and as woody has very
politely said
the few who are 26 years old and a
graduate of stanford berkeley and the u
of t
so not exactly the people we should
worry about
have all the gains and the rest of
population does not
and what we're doing in the network and
what we are thinking about is actually
figuring out
a whether it's true or not and i think
it's clearly not
and then wondering how what would he
call the incentives or
what other people might call different
innovation policies
lead different places countries
down at drifting trajectories of how we
innovate and
how the gains of our innovation are
distributed throughout their societies
and for whom
and that's exactly the discussion we're
starting at cfar
across multiple disciplines
so the question that i have for you both
is is in some ways a follow-up
to to that and kind of thinking through
different types of of innovation
um although it you know potentially with
a different meaning
um so everyone seems to be putting their
favorite adjective
in front of the word innovation whether
it's social innovation frugal innovation
inclusive innovation
um and so i'm curious to hear your
thoughts first are these
important or necessary distinctions to
make and if they are
why i'll start and
dan can pick up i think at one level all
of these are ways of trying to
soften or appropriate the term
innovation
or transform it so that the element of
it that has to do with novelty
and invention is is
retained but you shift the discussion to
ask
innovation for whom and i think it's
that
for whom that uh that is now a new um
framing that's that is necessary in
order to get people to think differently
about the gains from innovation
i agree i mean my fear
is that soon uh and since we are all
sort of socio-political economists in
this panel but
soon if we will continue to have social
innovation inclusive
innovation will end up like culture
meaning
uh it is encompassing everything and has
zero meaning by itself and i'm very
worried about that
um so i would say uh the good thing
about
those hyphen of innovation is that it
shows that people realize
how important innovation is to their
welfare and to their society
indeed we will all be stuck in our room
without innovation
all kind of innovation the people who
came with the vaccines
and as we in canada knows the people who
actually know how to
produce the vaccines are equally
important but i'm worried
that those hyphenated innovation has now
moving the debate
slightly offside and we are not asking
the really important question about
innovation growth equity and prosperity
anymore
there's a there's a question from the
audience um
that's kind of bringing us back so in
some ways to where we started
in talking about kind of place based
innovation
um and in this case it's specifically
coming from alberta canada
um where the um kind of innovation
in the economy has really been dominated
by fossil fuels and the energy sector um
although arguably now there seems to be
a shift to some degree to become
you know some version as you pointed out
silicon valley
uh of the north with a tech driven focus
around ai and whether or not an approach
like that
makes sense um again i think the
important
part here is is given alberta's
centrality around
fossil fuels and energy
so i'll start and and woody you you can
chip in um what is interesting for me
about
canada speaking about official it's that
there's actually two provinces
who are playing this game as we speak
one is alberta valves new finland
uh and they have both chosen completely
different strategies
uh in the past um
and then we have another case which i'm
really fond of but i think woody might
know even more
of a small country called norway also
like the same problem so if you look
across those cases
i think what is interesting in the two
cases that
i am slightly more inclined to say
have have chosen smart based on what
they have
is actually it might be newfoundland and
norway
um because what they have done is
realize what kind of
of skills they already have
in around that industry so
it's not just ai it's ai for mining
it's how to deal with ice it's
moving to what people call green tech
uh so you take your skills of knowledge
and you try to diversify
um to related industries or thinking
about
leap frogging but from the knowledge we
already have
um the other thing
which i think is as important is let's
assume for a moment that alberta
actually becomes silicon valley
what happens to all those people who now
works
in the industry at the moment
and the problem of trying to imitate and
move to silicon valley
even if it's successful to one or two of
alberta
cities is that it does not solve
the real looming problem and that is
that alberta
was the engine of an unbelievable amount
of
really good jobs for upper middle class
people
who are not graduate of the best
engineering schools
for all of canada this is unfortunately
coming to an end
i fear and it's not just a problem for
alberta but it's the problem for
all of canada is how to figure out
what kind of jobs or what kind of
innovation strategy
we can have that actually supplies good
jobs for those people
maybe thinking like north carolina
instead of thinking like silicon valley
might be the way
but woody what do you think about norway
as a model well
i was as you started talking i was
thinking norway would be an interesting
example for alberta where they take the
endowments
in the ground under the sea in the
skills
and use those endowments to make a
transfer into new
industries make investments in them but
i think the maybe the harder
issue is not like what do we do on the
ground but what goes on in people's
minds
um so you know in a place like alberta
texas lots of places where people
have um
reap prosperity from all ways of doing
things
change in doing something differently is
often seen as a threat
has a huge challenge they're trying to
take away
what we've done but a different way to
think about
innovation is not just that it's created
by outsiders but maybe
insiders want to change the way they're
doing things in order to remain on top
there's a great italian novel uh
lampedusa about
if you want things to ch if you want
things to stay the same you have to
change
um is the theme from that and you know
alberta at the moment has
the prosperity that could be used to see
beyond the world of fossil fuels
whether they have the mindset to do that
is of course a very different question
we have time for one or two more quick
questions and there's some great ones
coming in
uh so what is the role
of corporate governance um is really the
kind of at the heart of the issues that
you're talking about the distribution of
power
in the corporation who makes the
decisions who distributes the profit to
whom
um what corporate governance systems
work better for innovation
is this something that's internal to the
firm
or is regulation from state required
so did you want to be first or yeah i
guess you want me to go first because
that's
one such a phenomenally good question
and two such an incredibly hard question
okay and
[Music]
clearly the model of how boards ought to
operate or could operate
in the context of
entrepreneurial innovation has been a
huge challenge
because the people running the boards
have either been the vcs who backed the
companies
or the founders often with special
shares that allowed them to
have enormous influence
[Music]
for a continuing period of time and
thinking about
novelty and invention and corporate
governance i think is as important as
thinking about product
innovation so in one sense i'm punting
to say there's not enough work
being done on figuring out different
models of governance
that might have a longer time horizon
and also think more broadly about who
the beneficiaries of
of companies are there's some examples
they're often in somewhat exotic places
but now there are companies turning to b
corporations for example to say we have
both financial and social goals
uh there are others that have tried to
bring in stakehold different
stakeholders
but we need fresh thought about
innovation and corporate governance i
think
dan so i'll just add that it's not just
a corporate
um just look at what happened to boeing
and then start to think why it happened
and it happened because we also
change what are the legal requirement
from a ceo
a cfo to the shareholders
and the end result is boeing a company
which actually makes a lot of its money
on defense
catering more to short-termism on wall
street
and making decision where to allocate r
d funds
on changing body frames of airplanes
but ended up with a completely
unnecessary disaster like for max
partly because those decisions were
taking 15 years
before saying we don't have we are not
allowed
legally allowed to make those massive
investment into long-term r d
because the ceo would lose his job in
the real
job that i have now corporate governance
is to make shareholders happy
now and always now and that's a big
big issue that i think we have to tackle
but i think we're running out of time in
this session
uh in fact that is all we have time for
today
um i'd like to thank you both for
joining us i'd especially like to thank
um to thank all of you for joining us on
i'd especially like to thank dan and
woody for sharing your insights with us
um please visit cfar.ca to find out more
about this series to review recordings
of this and other
uh talks and um the recording from this
talk will be up next week thanks
everyone so long
thank you bye thank you for the
wonderful comments in the chat
[Music]
you